ebics hainard et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
là
bonjour et bienvenue dans livres et vous
votre émission littéraire qui par des
livres pour aller vers vous et qui vous
emmène aujourd'hui en montagne en
compagnie de mes 2 invités qui partagent
une même passion l'alpinisme au sens
propre et au sens figuré
le philosophe et physicien etienne klein
est habitué à la haute voltige
scientifique qui le rend accessible à
tous depuis des années son dernier livre
matière à contredire un essai de philo
physique publié aux édition de
l'observatoire s'interroge et répond à
toutes les questions que vous vous posez
sur le temps la causalité la matière et
le boson de higgs
mais oui il nous rejoindra à mi-chemin
de l'ascension que nous allons commencer
tout de suite en compagnie d'un écrivain
qui ne distingue pas l'avis de
l'écriture ni l'écriture du voyage il
fait paraître un été avec au maire aux
éditions équateur et s'ils n'ont pas une
saison mais une heure entière que nous
allons passer avec lui aujourd'hui
bonjour sylvain tesson beaux jours
bienvenue dans livres et vous merci vous
qui arpenter la planète à pied à cheval
à vélo qui dormaient dans des grottes
perdu est ce que la présence des livres
ici est rassurante ou plutôt angoissante
vous demander si la bibliothèque est une
grotte perdu oui
ah oui vraiment il reste une grotte qui
est fort bien isolée par des murailles
de papier c'est très bien et puis on y
rentre dans le silence
et puis on peut il rester longuement
même faire un feu après qu'on a lu alors
ce serait plus recommande on aurait des
petits problèmes avec l'autorité je me
rends très possible mais vous pourriez
peut-être y dormir on peut demander
d'autoriser sa l'autorisation parce que
vous aimez la vie un vieux c'est un
vieux rêve c'est de dormir dans une
bibliothèque et de penser qu'il parraine
un phénomène de rayonnement hélas ce
n'est pas le cas ça ne marche pas mais
ça va vite par un phénomène de
rayonnement on absorberait le tout la
science qui se tient dans ses livres se
contentant de dormir mais ça c'était un
rêve de cancre vous étiez un cancre
jaequi pas très intéressé par ce qu'il
veut dans les livres je préférais aller
voir jeter dehors et puis c'est je suis
venu très tard à la à la lecture
compulsive
enfin tard
[Musique]
après l'adolescence qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de lire je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas si tu agis comme on sait pas
très bien ce qu'il vous inocule un virus
mais ça l'aspect chez bras d'une
pathologie maintenant c'est à dire que
j'aime ce qui est imprimé je préfère me
rendre compte de la vérité des choses
par le mot plutôt que par la substance
des choses admet m
c'est embêtant mais surtout pour
quelqu'un qui voyage au temps qui va au
contact des choses oui c'est vrai mais
je mets souvent de l'écran d'un poème ou
d'une lecture d'un livre entre moi et
les épreuves que je suis ça m'arrive
souvent alors j'ai pour cela je prends
des livres absolument partout du choix
entre grimpé de deux marchés de dormir
dans la forêt et puis je n'ai rien à
lire je lis le manuel de de mécanique de
la motocyclette que je suis en train de
conduire ou le manuel de de réparation
de la machine à laver moldave sur
laquelle je fais mon mobile voit que ça
m'arrive de dormir parfois n'importe où
s'il ya un livre de littérature dont
vous voudriez jamais vous séparer ce
serait lequel
en ce moment parce que je vis donc on
n'est pas le même en se métamorphosant
se transforme en ce moment c'est au
maire moi je prends
permanence le disent et en plus on a la
chance d'avoir des nos traductions
différentes selon qu'on choisisse la
traduction de bejar ou le traduction
chaque côté on n'est pas dans le même on
n'est pas dans le même lit j'en ai pas
dans le même pot m alors en ce moment je
suis en train de dire que je n'aurais
d'une lire que cela au maire oui
l'odyssée en tout cas oui et que j'aurai
finalement eu le manuel des castors
juniors dans la poche et en même temps
que le bréviaire de de la vie réussie je
ne sais pas mais de l'avis diriger si on
dit que homer est le premier des
écrivains le premier romancier alors ça
veut dire que l'invention du roman elle
est inséparable d'un côté de la bataille
de la guerre c'est l'iliade et de
l'autre du voyage c'est l'odyssée qui
est le récit du retour d'ulysse ait
accès à dire que toute forme de
littérature est à la fois bataille et
voyage retour
oui peut-être enfin en tout cas ça ce
sont les thèmes narratif mais il ya il
ya le thème de la narration enfin il ya
le sujet mais le principe aussi parce
que omer s'est servi de ces deux thèmes
là que vous venez d'évoquer la bataille
voyage la guerre et le retour les hommes
et l'homme les tromper et l'individu la
violence et le tourment intérieur mais
aussi principe d'écrire quelque chose
qu'il n'est pas en train de se passer
mais qui est advenu dans le passé et
qu'on raconte
je crois que c'est ça le l'une des
inventions également donnèrent cse c'est
ce principe de la de la restitution de
ce qui est advenu du passé quoi il ya ce
moment franck et moi et mon chapitre
possédant dans l'odyssée aux hélices et
à la table des faits anciens qui sont
cette tribu qui l'accueille dans une île
et n'entend personne ne sait que c'est
lui il est il et incognito
je ne sais pas qui tu lis qui est là en
train de manger de la viande une boire
du vin est un poète qui est en train de
raconter ses aventures
donc on comprend que quelqu'un est en
train de parler d'un absent et je crois
que c'est là c'est ça la littérature
c'est de boucher les trous quoi c'est de
parler d'eux les fantômes c'est de
raconter le les histoires ivan uy lundi
se passe quelque chose et non pas de les
inventer parce que la littérature est
aussi affaire d'imagination
il est probable tout de même que homer
et tout inventé c'est de cette semaine
c'est mon avis ce qui est le plus
plausible il est probable que que les
femmes ne vole pas dans le ciel que les
sirènes ne soient pas des oiseaux qui
qui décapite les marins et qu'on ne
sorte pas d en faire ça c'est peut-être
probable enfin je suis pas sûr rires
parce que sait-on jamais donc il est
probable que la mythologie et non pas
durer si oui bien sûr il ay là il ya une
dictature de l'imagination
il se trouve que c'est pas du tout de la
mienne je suis incapable
hélas de camper des destins qui ne sont
pas dire je n'ai pas été témoin et des
histoires que je n'ai pas vécu
j'aimerais vous racontez vos expériences
dans vos livres pour récit de voyage
quand vous allez vivre six mois en
sibérie vos récits de traverser des
déserts dans tous les véhicules
possibles
vous avez un rapport à l'écriture qui
est celui sans doute d'une forme de
description de vous même en voyage et on
se demande alors ulysse on sait que son
but c'est de retourner chez lui à
ithaque
mais vous on a l'impression que vous
voulez toujours repartir votre but n'est
pas de rentrer mais de repartir oui
d'ailleurs on n'est pas absolument sûr
que cueilli une fois rentrée ne veulent
pas repartir
c'était là
à tori de jankélévitch alors qu'il
tentait de déceler chez ulysse une fois
rentré à ithaque une inquiétude c'est
son nom l'inquiétude du lys c'est à dire
que l'on peut supposer qu'après avoir
fait la guerre pendant dix ans et après
la fessée de circulation entre des
nymphettes des décès des magiciennes on
peut maintenant dix autres années
pendant dix autres années on peut
supposer que ce soit légèrement ennuyé
au bout de quelques mois pour avoir
retrouvé la trace idéal pénélope qui
faisait de la broderie
il est peut-être possible qu'il en ai eu
marre et qu'il est urgent d'ouvrir gmac
cela ne s'est pas laissée à des
spéculations
alors moi je crois au à l'ennui est là
la peur de l'ordinaire jeu j'y crois
comme moteur de la de la fuite de
l'évasion soit du voyage
ça veut dire que peut être vous même
expérimenté cet ennui l'ordinaire mais
c'est parce que vous choisissez d'écrire
quand on fait de la littérature
s'intéresse au moment où ça bouge
voilà c'est ça je ne parle pas des
causes moi je ne raconte pas les motifs
de nettoyage
d'ailleurs si j'allais raconter il est
probable que je mentirais je dirais pas
que je pars pour m'ennuyer on a tous on
essaye toujours de faire bonne figure il
ya qu ici que j ai vérité de ce que vous
me posez avec l'islam mais ya très peu
de voyageurs qui avoue qu'il ne parte
que pour essayer d'échapper à un
châtiment de grisaille y voyez-vous
dérouleront de superbes motifs très
noble la découverte de l'autre l'étude
de telles langue inconnue et la
cartographie de tels espaces méconnu
mais très peu voir que c'est pour
échapper peut-être à soi-même et à une
certaine forme dans les amants du monde
on peut se demander lequel vous qualifie
souvent de l'écrivain aventurier comme
si l'aventuré était un moteur pour vous
on tient de jankélévitch puisque vous le
site y est vous le citez dans votre
livre en été avec omar la distinction
entre un aventurier un aventureux un
aventurier c'est celui qui en fait reste
bien sûr son fauteuil et se fait peur en
croyant se mettre en danger
quand l'aventuré qu'est celui qui
vraiment affronte l'aventuré celui des
gens qu'ils évitent ch qui osent
affronter l'avenir
comme si l'aventuré était toujours en
fait un rapport au temps et vert à 1
espèce d'ailleurs inconnu qui nous fait
avancer
oui oui bien sûr il ya cette dimension
de de l'inconnu et du 2 du
franchissement de l'imprévisible c'est
le ça pourrait être la définition
d'ailleurs que jankélévitch sortie de
cette formule magnifique l'homme brute
de faire c'était le redoute
je trouve ça super parce qu'il ya la la
la tentative de passer les parapets de
l'angoissé de la peur alors tout ça est
très relatif
mais pour certains les angoisses enfin
l'angoissé quelque chose d'extrêmement
subjectif et le seuil n'est pas le même
selon qu'on soit téméraires ou timorée
mais n'empêche que timoré ou téméraire
si on réussit pas c'est le cercle du feu
de son angoisse
là on est dans l'aventuré et sur
laventure c'est ce qu'on ne peut pas
si c'est ce qu'on ne peut pas maîtriser
donc c'est l'acceptation de sa se blesse
alors à partir du moment où vous lancer
dans quelque chose vous n'êtes pas sûr
d'être celui qui va dominer et arriver à
ses fins on peut dire que vous êtes dans
un intervalle d' aventure et dans ce cas
pas besoin de parcourir la planète pour
vivre des aventures mais si justement il
y en a qui sont obligés je suis d'accord
avec vous que l'on peut tout à fait
imaginer que cette émission est une
aventure on peut dire ça on peut dire ça
bien sûr bien sûr le mot est très large
les mots sont généreux les mots ouvrent
les bras alors ils ouvrent les bras
toutes les notions et à toutes les
définitions enfin si on ne veut pas dire
c'est par mois 2 de prétendre que l'on
il faut essayer d'être sérieux en
cernant la définition des mots mais il
faut à mon sens qu'il y ait une
dimension de sanctions vital dans la
dans le sentiment qu'on vit une aventure
il faut qu'il ya un danger physique
parce que sinon encore une fois cet
intervalle d'inconnus est moins sévère
il faut qu'il soit un tribunal cet
intervalle de l'inconnu et que vous
puissiez risquer votre vie
à ce moment là je crois qu'on peut
affublé cet intervalle du mode aventure
dans l'iliade et l'odyssée alors il ya
beaucoup d' aventure très différentes on
a dit d'apprendre l'iliade c'est une
aventure belliqueuses du combat la
guerre de troie dans l'odyssée c'est une
aventure plus qui s'étire dans le temps
peut-être plus mélancolique plus
angoissante selon les lecteurs
mais dans les deux cas nous avons
affaire à des hommes des décombres a
appelé ce sont des des grands hommes que
ce soit des des héros des dieux dans la
première partie ou ulysse et on se dit
en le lisant que c'est peut-être une
littérature de l'héroïsme alors que le
terme aujourd'hui n'a plus du tout le
même sens est-ce que vous pensez que
ulysse est un héros et que le héros
serait celui qui pas qu'ils osent
rentrer chez lui contrairement à ce
qu'on croit oui je crois que la
définition que donne au maire du héros
comporte beaucoup de dax
et notamment celui de la gomme en avait
ça de la non pas de la de la certitude
qu'il ne faut pas dévier de la ksk on se
choisit gens que ça c'est une tension
qui surnage qui flotte au-dessus de
l'iliade et l'odyssée l'héroïsme pour
polluer aux grecs c'est de ne pas
déroger l'opiniâtreté le pédiatre eta sa
règle que ce soit sur un champ de
bataille
que ce soit pour la reconquête de sa
femme ou bout que ce soit pour le retour
dans son île pour restaurer le pouvoir
quoi il ya un moment il faut absolument
que être fidèle à son serment
et puis après il ya des tas d'autres
définitions que au maire d'issy de foxer
fait le héroïsme la définition de
l'héroïsme et une grande ratatouille
d'intel en met plein d'ingrédients oria
évidemment la force et la beauté ont
fait tout ce qu'on veut le l'aspect de
l'héroïsme les atours de l'héroïsme mais
aussi la notion de l'art de la
continuité de soi même dans la mémoire
des hommes c'est ça l'action héroïque
c'est ce qui fera qu'on ne vous oubliera
pas me semble-t-il c'est pour ça que
dans dans l'iliade il ya toujours ce et
ses scènes extravagantes où les héros
sont prêts à tout sacrifier à aller
au-devant des périls les plus dangereux
simplement pour faire un beau geste et
pour qu'il ne soit pas oublié
le renault alors vous avez raison
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus du tout
là mais le héros n'est que le reflet des
vertus qu'une société ou une
civilisation à un moment donné je mettre
en avant aujourd'hui ce que notre temps
veut célébrer ce n'est plus la cua la
salle est plus heureux non ce n'est plus
la renommée ce n'est plus la beauté j'y
pense pas non mais quand même l'héroïsme
a toujours une valeur et le fait de
vouloir marquer les esprits restent très
présents que ce soit dans l'est dans les
attentats qui sont commis alors là pour
le coup c'est un geste qui se veut pour
les auteurs même sans doute héroïque
qu'à un seul homme qui va se sacrifier
au nom d'une cause supérieure qu'elle
soit dieu ou autre chose
oui c'est vrai qu'il y avait déjà eu une
volonté de médiatisation
à l'époque d'homère alors pas par les
mêmes moyens qu'est-ce qu'il n'y avait
pas cette caisse de résonance immédiat
qui tout à coup explose la surface de
nos écrans sur terre mais il y avait
l'espérance qu'on soit inscrit dans la
mémoire mais c'est pareil c'est la même
c'est la même volonté
il ya eu quand même ensuite des
injections d'autres au fur à mesure que
les temps passés après l'italie et il
doit même la révélation chrétienne où
soudain le héros est devenu celui qui
pouvait se porter au secours de l'autre
ça c'est assez absents il ya l'amitié il
ya l'amour qui est là dans nos mers
mais ce n'est pas elle ce n'est pas la
définition de l'héroïsme ne passe pas
par la capacité à se sacrifier soi même
physiquement pour la survie du projet
locarno beltrame qui s'est sacrifié lors
des attentats de trèbes le 23 mars
dernier aux chrétiens chrétien c'est un
héros qui passera à la postérité donc il
ya un aspect grecque parce que il ya le
il ya la force et la bri piles de type
avait cette stature il a fait c'est
l'action était peut-être mais naked ride
mais ce sacrifice pour de soi même pour
la survie d'une personne de la femme en
l'occurrence qui l'a sauvé c'était un
héros compassionnel compassionnel oui
chrétien je crois oui bien sûr mais
c'est ça qu'il faut aussi quelques
figures du héros et c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette thématique de l'héroïsme
et tellement enfin brûlante en nous
c'est que cette figure philosophie qui
est presque métaphysique d'ailleurs du
héros est toujours contraint d'annoncer
pour le type sociétal qu'elle incarne
quoi dire elle est la figure de ce que
nous sommes vous écrivez dans toujours
dans votre livre en été avec aux moeurs
dans nos sociétés contemporaines le
héros ne ressemble plus à ulysse les
sociétés produisent des héros qui leur
ressemblent dans l'occident du 21ème
siècle le migrant où le père de famille
la victime ou le démunis seront dignes
du podium oui oui alors payer avait
avait formulé cette idée que le héros
qui peut sembler figure très banal et
qui me dit très très mezzo voce père de
famille il expliqué que c'était la
nouvelle aventure de la modernité et
c'était eux c'est lé père de famille les
véritables héros soit semblerait tout à
fait étrange pour un grec de l'époque
homérique qu'on puisse associer le terme
d'héroïsme à quelqu'un qui se contente
d'être un père de famille nous nous le
comprenons parce que le l'immense
adoucissement la grande tendresse de la
révélation chrétienne a tout à fait
changer notre vision de la définition du
bureau
alors après il ya effectivement
également l'idée de la de la victime
c'est ça être une ville fière de
victimisation aujourd'hui ça veut pas
dire que c'est la victimisation parce
que victimisation c'est l'idée qu'il ya
un glissement péjoratif qui viserait à
utiliser le fait que nous soyons des
victimes pour essayer de se mettre de se
mettre en valeur ou de se mettre sous la
lumière
ça veut simplement dire qu'aujourd'hui
la faiblesse la faiblesse que dont nous
sommes dont nous pouvons éventuellement
être la victime
que ce soit parce que nous avons
souffert dans une enfance ou parce que
nous avons été la victime d'une
adversité d'un accident de l'injustice
peut faire 2 ou la personne qu'on commet
en lumière comme on mettait en lumière
celui qui était fort celui qui était
capable de violence à l'époque d'homère
voilà où il ya eu une une transfert de
la définition donc un homme non viril
pour être un héros aujourd'hui alors que
oui oui il me semble utile ou et oui on
ne trouve pas telle figure dans dans
dans liane dans l'odyssée c'est quand on
la compagnie avec ses personnages
décrits par des cris par homère et donc
décrit par vous dans ce livre sylvain
tesson est très agréable on va cesser
ses héros mythologique au sens fort du
terme on a envie de rester avec lui vous
dit d'ailleurs que vous pourriez passer
davantage de temps avec ses héros votre
bibliothèque avec la compagnie des êtres
humains
pourtant parfois la réalité vous parler
de la vie ordinaire bas rattrape ce que
nous sommes
vous avez été vous même du crime d'un
accident vous aimez vous avez une
particularité c'est que vous aimez faire
de l' escalade vous allez alors
escalader les montagnes mais aussi les
toits les maisons les églises vous
dormez sur les églises puis un jour
c'était en 2014 vous le racontez dans
votre journal une très légère
oscillations vous êtes tombé dessus de
10 mètres de haut et la façon que vous
avez de le raconter est aussi de
proposer une forme de réflexion sur ce
qu'est l'accident et on parlait de l'
aventure on est en belle aventure c'est
s'exposer à l'imprévu cet accident me
semble-t-il ne vous révèle pas quelque
chose que vous n'aviez pas entrevu c'est
pas vraiment une aventure c'est ce qu'il
ya de très humain au fond deux pas du
tout mythologique c'est l'accident quoi
oui j'aurais beaucoup aimé ça c'est
beaucoup de plaisir j'ai trébuché
c'était c'était une maladresse et
j'aurai beaucoup peiné moi que ça me
tout à coup de sam ouvre la perspective
de comment pourrait-on dire d'un
assagissement ou même d'une révélation
d'une illumination peut-être même mais
ça c'est pas vrai
en fait on se réveille certain que l'on
va se réformer et en espérant se
transmettent à mort faisait et puis
finalement en guérit et qu'est ce que
c'est que guérir c'est simplement faire
en sorte que les vieux démons se
réveillent alors à ce moment là on
s'aperçoit qu'on va mieux parce que
précisément on recommence allait moins
bien
c'est ça le hellas
les raisons quand on commence à nouveau
à vieillir à se réinstaller dans ce
qu'on était et à reprendre ses mauvais
penchants c'est que c'est bon on est
guéri pour regretter presque d'être
guéri je regrette de ne pas avoir la
profondeur suffisante pour avoir pu
accueillir toute l'expérience que qu
aurait dû normalement me le procurer ses
petits malheurs que j'ai mis tout ça
vous dit quelque chose de très fort dans
votre journal vous dites que vous avez
appris une chose c'est que mépriser sa
douleur fait reculer la maladie
oui oui vous accueillir la douleur il
faut au contraire la nier la rejeter
alors on peut aller mieux
oui j'ai bien compris jean jacques
rousseau stoïciens là pour le coup c'est
oui l'oubli à l'oubli cas d'oubli
l'oubli et enfin le mépris c'est
difficile parce que parfois la douleur
hurle tellement que ne vous ne pouvez
pas le non plus totalement la mépriser
mais d'attaché de l'oublier donne pas
trop en parler ou d'en parler avec une
distance enfin c'est bien connu beaucoup
de malades se rétablissent avec eux
mêmes un essai de conversations très
légèrement sarcastique presque scénique
et je crois que ça participe de leur
émission c'est à dire que trop radio
signer sur ses petits malheurs trou
clapoter dans le respect de
considération de ces problèmes se finit
par faire masser c'est comme si comme un
exemple vous savez quand vous avez une
plaie s'il faut la désinfecter l'oubli
est un désinfectant qui finit par vous
lasser
il faut se chlorés de ses malheurs on
pourrait presque parler de déni
oui oui je crois même qu à terme de
psycho comme en essonne et psychologues
qui est humble l'anosognosie c'est à
dire l'absence de lass de la
compréhension de soi même enfin
l'absence de compréhension de ce qu'on
éprouve c'est peut-être le déni ce qui
m'a l'encontre de tous les discours de
développement personnel aujourd'hui ou
faut apprendre à se connaître pour être
en bonne compagnie nom vous dit en fait
quand on souffre il vaut mieux se tenir
à distance deux noms mm dont le sous
développement personnel
ces développements versa et pourtant
quand vous êtes à l'hôpital vous lisez
beaucoup pour aller mieux quand même
bien vous avez un rapport à la lecture
notamment un livre de cynthia fleury la
philosophe le pretium doloris que vous
avez préfacé et qui décrit ce l'accident
le sous-titré l'accident comme souci de
soi ouais tu absolument et elle m'a
appris une chose c'est une ti a fleuri
donc voilà la deuxième chose que j'ai
appris après cette nécessité d'oublier
grâce aux pressions de loris de cynthia
fleury grâce à l'odyssée c'est qu'il ne
faut pas totalement déconner avec la la
banalité des choses la douceur des
choses c'est quand ulysse revient à itea
qu'on a on à volonté tendance à ricaner
en disant il va s'emmerder avec pénélope
après avoir vécu toutes ces aventures
monde il va devoir faire la vaisselle le
pauvre mais en fait cette vie douce
cette bonne vie les lueurs du soleil le
soir sous la véranda tous ces trucs là
qui vous paraissent maigres quand vous
avez vingt ans parce que vous êtes
idiots et vient au bout d'un moment
quand vous avez failli l'épée adele se
révèle à vous c'est ce que je dirai très
banales mais
c'est malheureusement ces choses
ordinaires on a aidé on met des
décennies allait saisir dans toute leur
intensité et le livre de cynthia fleury
le prix de la douleur et puis évidemment
l'odyssée m'ont permis de ne plus jamais
laisser passer un moment de douceur
d'apparence banale
il faut continuer à voyager encore
escalader encore ouais bah oui plus que
je m'aime
parce que cette douceur que vous
décrivez on peut la trouver chez soi oui
mais encore une fois je les vieux démons
sont venus et j'ai toujours cette espèce
de besoin permanent de deux mouvements
moi j'ai l'impression d'être bien que
quand je reprends la mer comme dirait
oui sauf que moi c'est pas la mer c'est
plutôt continentale mais c'est le
mouvement
j'ai besoin de voir défiler le jour a
fini - la géographie parce que je ne les
ai pas encore niveau est géographe de
formation
oui enfin mode est ce que j'ai fait
quelques émules mais vous en peut vous
en parlait beaucoup et vous dit vivre
dans la géographie c'est franchir la
distance entre la chair du lecteur et
l'abstraction du texte des choses
magnifiques à dire sur la géographie qui
seraient entre les deux entre le lecteur
et le texte oui il ya le paysage quoi en
fait c'est à dire entre le tout à coup
il y avait la terre avec les éléments
les jeux morphologie la tecktonik enfin
le substrat enfin l'argile épilogue est
arrivé on a fait quelque chose qui
s'appelle le paysage où le terroir j'ai
pas comment il faut dire et puis parfois
le peintre lapin le musicien la chantait
le poète la dcri et tout ça est un et un
écho de la même chose quoi c'est une
espèce de production à partir d'un
terreau et moi je crois beaucoup que
nous sommes les enfin la phrase est pas
de moi et les lawrence durrell nous
sommes les enfants de nos paysages une
phrase superbe alors je ne suis pas un
déterministe farouche et bien je ne dis
pas que parce qu'on est nés dans des
grandes chaleurs et dans le calcaire en
sort on sera comme ça et parce qu'on est
né dans les brumes de ragnetti qu'on
sera autrement psychologiquement je dis
que tout de même il
il peut y avoir une prédisposition de
l'esprit à certains paysages c'est pas
tout à fait pareil d'être un homme de la
montagne des ternes hommes de la vallée
d'être un homme de la pente est d'être
un homme de la platitude d'être un homme
de la canicule est d'être un homme du
froid je crois que nous sommes des
animaux et que du coup il ya une
imprégnation psychophysiologiques vous
n'êtes plus un homme de la montagne vous
oui enfin ça dépend parce qu'il faut
encore faut-il préciser altitude parce
que je sais pas de la glace moi je suis
un homme de la forêt on va aller très
haut vers la glace et vers la neige pour
accueillir le deuxième invité qui va
nous rejoindre à présent qui est lui
aussi un amoureux des des sommets au
sens propre comme au sens figuré
il va nous rejoindre le temps d'une
ascension celle de l'annapurna par
l'alpiniste maurice
certes ça que c'était en 1962 chaque
jour les nuages sont là
la victoire que nous sentons à notre
portée tiens à quelques heures de beau
temps
nous approchons du moment attendu depuis
des mois une intense surexcitation de
grogne
tous nos efforts n'aboutiront il qu'un
échec à quelques heures du but nous nous
élevons et puis nous sommes aveuglés par
les tourbillons de neige soulevée par le
vent
il faut contourner dimanche crevasse
à chaque pas nous enfonçons jusqu'à mes
jambes
le pénétrons dans un monde étrange
qui n'appartient presque déjà plus à la
terre
peut-être complètement hypnotisé par ce
qu'on regarde l'un à l'autre ça fait
plaisir bonjour à vos etienne klein
bonjour un monde étrange qui
n'appartient déjà plus à la terre ça ce
que disait le commentaire de cette
archive nina qui date de 1962 près de
dix ans après l'ascension de l'annapurna
c'est une bonne manière de décrire ce
lieu haut sinon oui cette amende
aventure au sens propre du terme puisque
en l'occurrence maurice herzog n'était
pas tout seul il a aussi louis lachenal
qu'on ne m'oublie souvent qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas la même version sur ce
qui s'est passé tout à la fin c'est dire
bon bah et il avait les pieds qui
commençait à geler il l'a fait savoir à
maurice herzog qui était un peu perdu
dans ses pensées et la finale est restée
avec lui jusqu'au bout il y a perdu ses
pieds parce que dit il c'était une
affaire de corner on laisse pas
quelqu'un tout seul mais à l'huile m
certes tant qu'ils ont risqué leur peau
donc ça rejoint la définition de
l'aventuré par sylvain tesson mais n'ont
laissé là-bas que des morceaux pop
puisqu'ils ont perdu leurs pieds les
mains pour herzog et seulement les pieds
pour la finale en plus d'être philosophe
et scientifique vous escalader les
montagnes est une classe que vous
escaladez les bibliothèques aussi comme
sylvain tesson wilshere les hypothèques
jusque là les sommaires par - l'
aventure que silva rien il fait des
périples très long je n'ai pas cette
patience et je craindrais de rencontres
et de l'ennui dans l' aventure même avec
c'est une affaire de patience et les
longères les opérations ils ont plus
coup de poing des sommets les courses
elle en vend avant d'en venir à votre
livre matière à contredire vous avez un
autre point commun l'un et l'autre c'est
un goût pour les anagrammes
grâce à jacques terry celle qu avec
lequel vous avez chacun publié un livre
l'anagramme donc une anagramme on se
trompe souvent consiste à prendre les
lettres qui composent un mot ou une
phrase à l'échangé d'ordre proposé un
autre mot ou une autre phrase alors
qu'elle serait l'anagramme de matière à
contredire etienne klein il y en a deux
il ya récréation à méditer
et il ya rédaction téméraire que ça une
fois qu'on rentre dans le monde des
anagrammes ou fonctionne comme ça et
vous vous connaissez l'anagramme de vos
titres sylvain tesson entre les gènes
oscillations denrées périssables qu a
eue de l'extrême gentillesse de faire
l'anagramme de bâtir d'un gramme de mon
nom sylvain c'est sylvain tesson ils
n'osent ou plurielle du verbe osé ils
n'osent vas-y agréable c'est agréable à
gramat le dit c'est une prolongation par
un sens caché de 2 du nom du mot
exactement moi c'est nein nein télé
n'ont pas quitté les abords etienne et
donc vous n'avez pourtant vous êtes à la
fin il ya des contradictions
moi j'espère qu'elle ne vous en voudra
pas votre livre se présente comme un
essai de philo physique et vous
présenter les deux disciplines comme
étant à distinctes la philosophie d'un
côté la physique de l'autre vous dites
sont de matière absolument distinctes et
pourtant vous les avez étudié ensemble
et vous vous présentez aujourd'hui comme
philosophe des sciences
oui en fait l'idée c'est de se mettre
entre les deux disciplines reconnaître
leur distinction l'horeca et puis une
fois qu'on y entend les mets en
vis-à-vis et on regarde si elles peuvent
se mettre en tension autour de cette
question
la question du temps par exemple qui va
être gelée a pris plus de temps le sujet
de l'agrégation de philosophie en 2019
qu'est-ce qu'on parlera seulement deux
philosophes ou est ce qu'on pourra aussi
un peu de ce qu'on fait les physiciens
sur le temps newton einstein très vite
sur le temps donc il ya des questions
comme celle là quand les philosophes
part du temps il parle de quelque chose
quand les physiciens parle du temps il
parle de quelque chose
est ce que c'est la même chose et si la
réponse est non pourquoi c'est le même
mot et si la réponse est oui
la question est de savoir s'ils disent
les mêmes choses si la réponse est non à
qui est-ce qu'on accorde du crédit sans
intérêt d'un philosophe à l'autre il
pouvait avoir une définition différente
du temps et peut-être que c'est long
c'est quelque chose qui est en effet la
paire antique mais qui oblige à préciser
le sens des mots comme vous allez tenter
de faire tout à l'heure à propos du mot
aventure de quoi parle-t-on quand on
parle du temps et qui
légitimité pour en parler le mieux voilà
des questions qui m'intéresse et comme
les mots de la physique sont des mots
très anciens qui n'ont qui n'ont pas
changé depuis des millénaires le movie
de mots tant le mot espace le mot
énergie et matières et cetera ce qui a
changé c'est ce qu'on met derrière ces
mots mais du coup il faut adapter ce
qu'on en dit à ce qu'on en sait sinon on
risque de faire du commentaire de
commentaires de façon indéfinie et donc
je pense que la physique qui a repris
une partie de son vocabulaire à la
philosophie nous aide à mieux interroger
le sens que nous donnons aux mots parce
que la distinction oui parce que je les
pensais qu'après l'avoir écrit mais je
pense cette année sur le langage oui
c'est ça sur une définition des talents
d'un soir windstein et je crois que
c'est parce que ce qu'il dit du langage
le fait que les jeux de langage nous
entraîne dans des automatismes de penser
c'est ça que j'essaie de dénoncer en
montrant que la physique sur certaines
questions très particulière bien
réorienter les questions philosophiques
on peut poser à propos de ces notions
mais la différence il y en a beaucoup
entre la philosophie et la physique
c'est qu'en physique comme toute forme
de sciences il y à des avancées des
découvertes notre connaissance fiset en
physique change en fonction du temps
c'est peut-être le cas en philosophie
mais loyal l'expression de découverte en
philosophie je sais pas trop ce qu'elle
voudrait dire je citais en début
d'émission le boson de x par exemple qui
a pu changer notre approche même de la
physique est ce que ça rend pas les
choses encore plus compliquées que la la
nature même du sujet auquel s'intéresse
la physique évolue aussi bien sûr moi je
crois que la philosophie ça consiste en
partie à penser au delà de ce qu'on fait
mais il ya aussi des choses concède et
on doit en tenir compte
quand on essaie de penser au delà de ce
conseil on doit le pas négliger les
connaissances dans notre façon de penser
qu'un peu ce cas le message du livre
vous parliez de boson de higgs
eh bien il a changé de façon
révolutionnaire appelée nous que c'est
pas ta place est une particule qui a été
détecté en 2012 qu'elle était prédite
dès 1964 dont 48 en avant ce qui veut
dire que est capable de prédire par des
équations un nouvel élément de réalité
c'est quand même pas rien
ça veut dire que lévisien non pas des
cribles réel mais sont capables d'entrer
en contact avec quelque chose qui a à
voir avec le réel
sinon on l'aurait pas trouvé et si on
allait trouver il n'aurait pas eu les
caractéristiques on avait calculé au
paraguay
c'est pas qu'on a détecté ce qu'on l'a
reconnu on l'a reconnu dans des
toilettes découvert avant de l'avoir
rencontré on l'a prédit avant de
détecter
donc on la détecte et parce qu'on
connaissait en fait et donc ça veut dire
que on a un rapport avec la réalité qui
mérite d'être pris au sérieux comme
hills et paul claudel que style que cite
souvent clément rosset les choses qui
existent sont importantes
je connais pas de phrases plus banal et
en même temps là une profondeur
incroyable les choses qui existent sont
importantes et le fait que les grandes
théories physiques du 20e siècle
je pense que la physique quantique je
pense qu'à la relativité d'einstein a
restreintes et la générale c'est des
théories trop presque un siècle qui ont
été dénoncées à une époque on n'allait
pas de données sur l'univers elle est
très peu de données sur la matière dans
les années 20 qu'est ce qu'on sait sur
la matière connell protons électrons
connaît pas les forces nucléaires et des
gens avant une physique la physique
quantique qu'on utilise encore
aujourd'hui alors qu'on allait quark
l'eau boson de higgs les bosons
intermédiaire on sait que l'une et 30 en
expansion on connaît les trous noirs etc
ça veut dire que ces équations leur ont
un pouvoir qui mérite d'être interrogés
parce que ça nous dit des choses du
monde ça dit pas le monde des choses du
monde et me semble quand on dit
philosophe
ça doit être intéressant de les
considérer non seulement même sylvain
tesson c'est une vraie différence entre
l' approche littéraire l approche
scientifique telle que la décrit think
l'a essayé de dire des choses du monde
on peut faire le mariage entre l'homme
l'approché littéraire est l'approché
philosophique la passerelle se coupe si
on a une approche purement spéculatives
et abstract et une approche matériel
matérialiste qui prend en compte le réel
je crois que c'est c'est ça la
réconciliation qu'au père etienne klein
dans son livre la réconciliation entre
le scientifique et philosophe c'est la
défiance pour toute forme de pensée qui
ne s'articulent recteur sur
l'abstraction et la spéculation un
moment venu pour la réconciliation oui
c'est sa communication sur sa teinte
esprits pour la guerre non plus non la
distinction qu'il ya une distinction il
faut se trouver les moyens de discuter
autour certaines questions pas tout
parce que je pense qu'à des questions
philosophiques pour lesquels la science
n'est d'aucune utilité est par contre un
ado qui correspondent à un vocabulaire
commun qui mérite qu'on se mette autour
d'une table et qu'on discute qu'est ce
que tu appelles le temps qu'est ce que
j'appelle le temps qu'est ce que qu'est
ce qu'il ya de commun dans ce que nous
en dise on est qu'est-ce qui mérite
qu'on change nos avis je pense qu'il ya
certains résultats de physique qui ouvre
de nouveaux chemins de pensée pour les
philosophes mais réciproquement et des
philosophies qui permettent de mieux
dire ce qu'on apprend par la physique
il ya des intuitions philosophe qui est
des arguments de philosophes qui
corresponde parfois à des choses qui
sont découvertes par des physiciens
qu'eux mêmes n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de dire aussi bien vous disiez
vous même que certaines réalités
physiques avait été prédite avant d'être
rencontrés est-ce que le geste même de
pouvoir prédire quelque chose ce rapport
au monde que ça entraîne ne suffit pas
qu'elle que nous apporte la physique en
fait finalement la preuve par
l'expérience très endormir du temps on
regarde et on a découvert les ondes
gravitationnelles en 2016 pour traverser
la terre en 2015 présenté détecter ces
ondes ce type d'onde a été prédit par un
style en 1916 un siècle avant et on a
mis du temps à être capable de détecter
des phénomènes qui sont en semaine mais
le fait qu on ait pu les détecter comme
elle a été calculée et d'ailleurs leur
existence pour les gens des trous noirs
prouve que les troubles sont capables de
fusionner ça peut quand même très loin
on savait que la relativité générale
elle a profondément modifié les liens
entre l'espace et le temps du coup les
philosophes qui s'intéressent autant
doit entendre la détection des ondes
gravitationnelles comme un événement qui
les concernent
si la question du temps les intéressent
si elle ne les intéresse pas il peut
continuer comme d'habitude
est ce que l'université les enceintes de
recherche en france aujourd'hui
permettent cette communication cette
collaboration entre la science et la
philosophie parce qu on approche de
l'éducation très disciplinaire en fruits
mais on n'est pas obligé de maintenir
des silos entre les disciplines par
exemple quand le professeur de
philosophie en classe de terminale part
de l'atome à ses élèves il peut aussi
invité professeur de vie pendant une
demi-heure pour discuter et quand le
professeur de physique part de l'atome
il peut aussi invité le professeur de
philosophie pour dire en quoi l'idée
d'un tome est apparue en grèce ou
ailleurs
il ya plus de deux millénaires et en
quoi la tome des physiciens en fait
contredit l'atome idées philosophiques
d'atomes là donc on a découvert au xxème
siècle il ya aucune des propriétés que
les atomistes grecs avaient envisagé
n'empêche que c'est parce qu'ils ont
envisagé l'existence d'un objet qui
n'existent pas qu'on a pu au bout de
deux millénaires découvrir un objet qui
existent et qui n'est pas celui qui
avait dépensé clé c'est la question
c'est est-ce que c'était le même nom des
mêmes elles se posent avoue sylvain
tesson quand on lit quand on lit homère
est ce que c'est
est ce que au maire décrit le même monde
que le nôtre est ce que les atomistes de
les peuples peuvent décrire le même
monde qu'aujourd'hui où est ce que
finalement ce sont deux mondes
différents mais moi je pense que c'est
impossible quand on lit démocrite par
exemple de sanex anatomiste de savoir ce
qu'il avait dans la tête lorsqu'il
écrivait le mot vide à ce que nous quand
nous lisons le mot vide sous la plume de
démocrite nour est trop pro jetons
derrière ce mot des choses que nous
avons apprises depuis et qu'il ne
connaissait pas on imagine canada
apparemment on va penser que le vide
c'est un espace newtonien sans aucune
matière à l'intérieur c'est comme ça
qu'on pense que lille en général et
d'huile a pâli des espèces moutonnière
il n'a pas l'idée d'un espace abstrait
qui est indépendant des choses et donc
qu'est ce qu'il veut
quand il parle de vide je pense que là
et dans l'aventuré d'autant que valve
reste chez les antiques pour apprendre
et stable le vide n'existait pas et
voilà il découvrit que le néant et c'est
donc il ya toutes sortes de deux
problèmes d'interprétation du sens des
mots qui oblige à tout remettre en
perspective historique la physique et la
philosophie de la maison le vide ça vous
parle sylvain tesson vous êtes attiré
par le vide sur 7
je suis attiré par le vide abichou mme
abyss ou six nouveaux cas que le vide
appelle le vide
c'est une devise d'alpinistes il ya dans
le livre de cas ce moment où vous citez
la manière dont wahlbeck de manière
assez amusante d'ailleurs écrit que en
fait il a il se sent assez bien né en
mai alors effectivement c'est une
histoire de d'utilisation des mauges ont
beaucoup moi cette idée que les mots ont
été gravées dans le marbre mais que
craint toute la profondeur qui a changé
parce que lui il veut dire le désespoir
en finlande il t'a pas du néant comme un
espèce de vide que l'on finit toujours
par comblé par ce par sa propre
définition presse qu'il n'y avait pas
des filles ont vraiment dû vie parce que
si on dit le vide c'est ce qui reste
quand on a tout enlevé ben si on l
enlève absolument tout ce qui reste
c'est pas le vide le néant
donc le vide se mange est un gay le vide
d'une r8 le vide c'est quelque chose de
particulier
alors il ne faut pas le retirer quand on
enlève tout sinon elle a su plus rien
donc le vide c'est ce qui reste quand on
a tout enlevé sauf le vide autrement dit
pour décrire le vide il faut savoir une
théorie qui vous disent ce qui existe et
qui vous disent ce qu'ils pensent qu'il
existe peut être retirée ou pas et donc
il faut une physique donc cqfd
mais alors ça veut dire que si je vous
comprends bien et pour le monde lui-même
d'un point de vue scientifique
justement pour être compris doit être
doit rentrer dans certaines théories
mais d'où vient l'idée même que le monde
devrait être compris par des lois vous
poser la question alors ça ces lois là
est ce que c'est vrai au prix de
l'imaginaire des questions métaphysiques
telle que je pense pas que la physique
répondre à un jour la question de savoir
quel est le statut des lois physiques
celui qui est l'idée qu'il ya des lois
mathématiques sable c'est galilée il
pensait lui à des lois mathématiques à
part la géométrie en fait c'est plutôt
les équations différentielles qu'ils
sont
l'expression des vraies lois de la
physique disait que les mathématiques en
parle en tout cas une partie d'entre
elles peut permettre de décrire le monde
si diageo on est dans une bibliothèque
il n'y a pas vraiment de symétrie
national un peu l'idée que des équations
peuvent décrire ce qui se passe là
l'absurde et pourtant c'est l'idée qui
marche et c'est une idée qui m'a
d'autant mieux que on a compris c'est
gagner je crois qu'elle premier à
l'avoir senti que les lois physiques
sont des lois qui contredisent
l'observation
donc on ne peut pas les avons peu pâle
est tiré du spectacle du monde
il faut aller bricoler il faut faire des
hypothèses faire des expériences
maintenant si tu avais tomber des livres
de masse différentes ont pas tomber la
vitesse légale il est arrivé 10 tous les
lits retombe à la même vitesse quelles
que soient les menaces
donc la loi qu'il est non c'est une loi
qui est contredite par l'observation et
si on la prend au sérieux il faut
réinterroger les réinterpréter
l'observation pour montrer comment une
loi qui l'a contredit il explique quand
même j'ai quand même rigolo ça veut dire
que les lois font partie du monde ne
sont pas dans l'esprit c'est pas nous
qui inventent ont des lois ce qu'elle le
monde est vraiment construit à partir de
ces lois ce soir on sera jamais on se
sent vraiment prêt en tout cas c'est
nous qui écrivons les lois est ce que
les lois c'est ce que les lois de la
nature sont différents des lois de la
physique les lois de la physique s'est
mobilisée est-ce que les est ce que la
nature les connaît ou est-ce que c'est
nous qui prouvent ce sont ces lois dans
notre façon de comprendre la nature bon
pour pour le savoir il faut être capable
de sortir de son esprit vous parlez de
nature aussi dans votre liste oui parce
que le c'est une idée vertigineuse de se
dire que à un moment donné de l'histoire
de l'humanité
on a notre disposition une panoplie de
définition des joies de la nature mais
qui va changer au fur à mesure que les
connaissances vont vont être de plus en
plus pointues c'est vertigineux parce
que dans la pensée antique enfants est
essentiellement lapointe sommeil qu il
ya l'idée que la bonneville avait des
sociétés doit être régi par une sorte de
décalque de la delà des lois naturelles
mais les lois naturelles à l'époque de
mer ne sont pas les mongols naturel que
notre époque
etienne klein vient de l'expliquer et la
loi naturelle à laquelle on pense quand
il s'agit d'organiser les sociétés c'est
celle que voilà le battement des saisons
l'appelaient les meubles équilibre
l'harmonie la loi du plus fort parce que
va grosses bêtes mangent la petite bête
alors ces voix là ce sont deux stades
déploiement de loi observable le assez
rapidement au compréhensible et qui sont
finalement superficiel mais si on pense
aux lois de la relativité il est évident
que l'application à des sociétés
humaines n'est plus possible si
brutalement mais la présence de la
nature chez homère elle est intéressante
elle est pas celle des lois ou plutôt
des lois finalement de la guerre il ya
le combat de le combat d'achille et la
nature qui sont de type tête de combat
différent et ça vous vous séparez de la
proposer une sorte de réflexion sur
l'écologie vous dites en termes
écologiques qui ont dit que les signaux
d'alerté dans le rouge en termes
mythologiques
on dit que les fleuve déborde de dégoût
ne comprenait pas encore nous ne
comprenons pas encore qu'il faut
ralentir notre course vers ce gouffre
oui il y à ce moment très précis de
l'iliade qui constitue un champ la
colère d'achille et en magie devient
foule il sort de lui même il se déchaîne
dans la violence et à ce moment là c'est
le cosmos entier qui se rebellent contre
lui qui se dégoûte même les dieux sont
dégoûtés de la folie des hommes alors
qu'ils ont excité les hommes à la guerre
mais tout à coup la guerre échappe aux
hommes alors c'est peut-être
l'ordonnancement qui se détraque
et c'est la folie cisq dgac appelé le
bri et la démesure ces déchaînements
c'est la dinguerie absolue et les fleuve
déborde pour essayer d'arrêter des
hommes et à ce moment là on peut tout à
fait faire une analogie avec eux tous
nos espèces de signaux d alerte qui
aujourd'hui ce sera
weir partout sur le dans la grande
marmite planétaire et qui fait une
analogie politique aux fins qui tentent
de lettres et on pourrait tout à fait
imaginer qu'il y a une une tentative de
phishing dallaire d'essayer d'arrêter
notre know débordements comme la même si
la mythologie avait un peu force de loi
en fait on pourrait le dire comme ça
c'est une manière aussi de conduire sa
vie d'interagir avec sa propre planète
de que de le voir enfin en termes
mythologiques et pas simplement
scientifique mais en tout cas il ya
l'idée sous jacente dans les deux poèmes
dans l'iliade et l'odyssée qu'il ya un
ordre la fac et d'une harmonie plus à
kazan équilibre et qui fait que les
plantes poussent que des bêtes survivent
que dès que les espèces se propage et
que tout tient parce qu'il y en ait un
équilibre et que si on vient interrompre
et désordonnée c'est cet équilibre alors
là on a des chaînes de mauvaises force
et hennequin oui enfin je sais pas si on
est capable d'entendre la leçon c'est à
dire que d'un point de vue scientifique
les choses sont assez claires sur le
dérèglement climatique sur les problèmes
liés à la biodiversité etc
on le sait mais on a du mal à le croire
comme si les messages bien que très
connue n'était pas entendue parce qu'il
nous dérange trop en fait
et on attend de voir plus les dégâts
pour se mettre d'accord pour agir contre
l'impuissance de l'observation pour le
nom c'est con pour n'est capable de
déployer des stratagèmes intellectuelle
pour ne pas croire ce qu'on sait pour le
mettre de côté son biais de la télé on
attend qu'ils se montrent davantage
on compte sur je ne sais quel
bienveillance du cosmos pour que les
dégâts soient moindres
vous êtes à la réunion la semaine
dernière juste après mon départ il ya eu
une tempête un presque un cyclone
les vents étaient 245km vraiment pas 150
qu'il fallait pour que puisse parler
d'un cyclone et quand on veut j'ai vu
des images et quand on voit cela on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de l'interpréter
comme une colère de la nature même si on
sait que derrière ce sont les lois de
nabeul x tones
joie la mécanique des fluides qui gère
la terre avant que vous mettiez en
colère l'un et l'autre je vous propose
de vous partager vos choix littéraires
on vous a demandé à tous les deux de
venir avec vos livres de chevet ou les
livres qui avait compté pour vous
sylvain tesson quels sont les livres que
vous avez choisi déportés de carmoy j'ai
pris le philip k.dick toutes les
nouvelles de philip k dick eux sont sans
distinction parce que ce type on dit
dans les îles 60 comme une espèce de
prémonition extraordinaire que notre
civilisation s'acheminer vers un
remplacement des hommes par les choses
et par les machines et je crois que
c'est parce que nous vivons
alors c'était pas directement formulées
dans les termes que nous éprouvons
aujourd'hui avec la cybernétique enfin
il y avait il avait compris que tout à
coup nous sommes allés à l'hercules et
que les dieux allait disparaître et que
la substance humaine
allez y perdre perdre le combat voilà et
puis alors vous dessus ses livres de
chevet que vous ayez alors mon livre de
chevet j'ai pris mon vrai qu'ils ont
fait connaître les fleurs du mal de
baudelaire parce que parce que je
raisonne en permanence en moi et parce
que le temps l'espace l'amour la douleur
la mort enfin tout est là quoi je sais
pas si c'est un ouvrage d'astrophysique
mais presque toutes à vue par un poète
et puis j'ai sur en les caillassant qui
était le laboratoire de l'écriture de
tous les aphorismes de sueur en il ya
d'ailleurs quelque chose astrophysique
dans lesquels sûr il ya la phrase ou
édifices édition rang absolu
j'ai appris ce matin qu'il y avait 14
milliards de galaxies est il forcément
j'ai renoncé à faire ma toilette c'est
écroulement devant l'immensité du monde
a faim voilà cette forme lapidaire qui
est merveilleuse
et puis c'est cette énergie c'est de
cette incroyable énergie convoqué pour
pour affirmer le désespoir ce qui est
contradictoire parce que tant qu'ils
l'affirment essai clinique n'était pas
complètement a enseveli sous le
par la peur de crouler sous le poids de
la tristesse mais pourtant c'est elle
qu'il affichait avec beaucoup d'humour
aussi faut le dire que vous en lien
qu'on a on a évalué à 4 milliards
d'années l'âge de la terre je vois si
c'est ça exactement plus maintenant mais
alors disons 5
j'y pense ce matin où je ressent le
poids vertigineux d'un autre jour à
supporter des reds et woody allen
etienne klein quels sont vos choix
littéraires émission l anagramme 1
seront là bien sûr en ces l'acrimonie
l'acrimonie magnifique alors on a parlé
de gérer cette bourse est un ami commun
et j'appelle des cafés des anagrammes
extraordinaire il en trouve des
extraordinaires mais il vient de publier
un livre de palindromes l'inde rom cd
phrase qu'on peut lire à l'identique
dans les deux cas yak est un bon gars à
dreux là c'est comme ça qu'ils se
calment fait drôle ça c'est rêver sont
des palindromes et lui il arrive à
trouver des phrases entières par exemple
fiancé va avec naïf et puisqu'on parlait
du lys zeus a été fêté à suez
et puis on a beaucoup d'autres il y
avait même des menus entier de repas
gastronomique rédigé en palindrome bien
s'appelle vivarium de palindromes
ensuite y'a pas ce que clément rosset
vient de nous quitter c'est est un
philosophe eux dont je crois j'ai tous
les livres qui disent tous l'anader mais
écrit beaucoup pourquoi la mezam après
tout la même chose il reconnaît lui même
n'a aucune idée le réel n'a pas de
double et dans cette esquisse
biographique
il répond aux questions de san diego et
spinoza
ils racontent beaucoup d'anecdotes sera
montre avec derrida derrida qui était
intarissable dit-il avec foucault et
c'est là qu'ils parlent de claudel dans
la france que je citais tout à l'heure
les choses qui existent sont importantes
et voilà j'étais très triste d'apprendre
son décès y ait quelques semaines
d'autant que clément rosset c'est lui
qui disait que est la suite de
baudrillard que le réel n'avait jamais
nantes je n'ai pas donc que le real
n'avait jamais intéressé personne et
quand même temps qui avait rien de plus
difficile que de que de nommer ce réel
nom vous dit les choses qui existent
sont importantes en fait c'est toute la
philosophie de clément rosset qui se
trouve là dedans voilà et puis un livre
de françois jullien qui vient de
paraître qui s'intitule si près tout
autre de l'écart et de la rencontre
procès julien c'est un philosophe
sinologue helléniste qui essaie de
penser
l'impensé de la pensée occidentale par
exemple la pensée chinoise dont qui se
perd entre on pratique les cas et je
pense que c'est un peu ce qui nous
intéresse tous d'être entre dans ce cas
c'est ce qui vous intéresse entre la
philosophie et la science
voilà et puis dans les voyages au s'il
ne pas rester au même endroit avoir une
forme de de bougeotte à la fois physique
intellectuel parce que la pensée a quand
même à voir avec le mouvement
merci à l'un et à l'autre en tout cas
d'être venu de nous parler de vos
ouvrages alors je les rappelle sylvain
tesson un été avec home edition équateur
ainsi qu'une très légère oscillations
dans à parler votre journal de 2014 à
2017 aux éditions des équateurs
etienne klein matière à contredire et
cette fille au physique aux édition de
l'observatoire
encore une information un festival que
je crois vous connaissez sylvain tesson
le festival étonnants voyageurs à saint
malo et déjà les oui bien sûr stival de
michel lebris sur les remparts voilà et
ça se passe comment obrecht très bien
j'ai ce passe le jour espèces la nuit
nous n'en dirai pas plus à ce tient ce
week-end en tout cas du 19 au 21 mai on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine même
heure même endroit mais avant cela on se
quitte
comme chaque semaine avec une chanson il
a fallu trouver une chanson qu'ils
allaient nous conduire sur le toit du
sénat on va essayer de pas tomber cette
fois ci un groupe qui s'appelle de
postal service je sais pas si vous
connaissez cette chanson en particulier
qui sur les hauteurs such bright lights
merci à tous les deux c'est une chanson
ascensionnel
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
mais c'est moi que je
m
[Musique]
c'était livrez vous avec le concours du
centre national du livre
[Musique]